no all I'm doing here though this one
third comes from this and this one half
comes from that okay so where is this
where does this one third come from that
one-third comes from 16 plus one-sixth
which is that when are the situations
where one of the situations when we're
both event a and B have happened well if
I get a 1 both event a and B have
happened and if I get a 3 both event a
and B na out of a total of six yeah yeah
16 10 16 year exactly yeah yeah sorry I
misunderstood your question okay now in
a casual sense we think of two events
are independent if knowing that one
event has occurred doesn't affect the
probability of the other event right
that means if rain did not depend on the
month of the year then you telling me
that it's April would have no impact on
my assessment of the probability of rain
right if they were independent then I
wouldn't care whether it's May or June
or July so the conditional probability
would in that case simply be equal to
the unconditional probability that is
the probability of a given B is just the
probability of a the probability of a
given B is not affected doesn't affect
the probability of it so that's the
definition of Independence okay and so
of course if you apply this
two independent events you get that if
two events are independent then the
probability of their intersection is
simply the product of the probabilities
okay so you could just you could use
this definition and this definition to
derive that okay okay let's talk about
Bayes theorem we have 15 minutes so
we'll have just enough time to do Bayes
theorem and do an example of Bayes
theorem and maybe talk about probability
density functions Oh probability
distribution functions okay so say you
have two events a and B obviously these
two events give rise to two other events
not a and not B and as you've seen
already there's a way of denoting that
this is a compliment or B compliment
that means not a not peak and this is
specifically not a not be same thing
okay so a and a compliment or a and not
a comprise a partition of the sample
space now so Bayes theorem is concerned
with how the probability how is
concerned with expressing the
conditional probability that is the
probability of B given a in terms of the
probabilities of the compliments
okay so let me go back here this is the
definition of conditional probability
sometimes it's not easy for us to
compute the intersection probability or
the unconditional probability Bayes
theorem simply restates this in terms of
the compliment probabilities okay and so
I'll tell you let's go to Bayes theorem
and sometimes those probabilities might
be easier to compute so here is a
statement of the Bayes theorem
probability of B given a this
probability of B times probability of a
given B the reverse okay so it's very
easy to confuse these two but these are
two different probabilities over the
probability of a and you could work this
out it's actually not very simple to
work out just a bit of algebra and
applying the definitions a couple of
times or it could also be expressed as
probability of B times probability of a
given B so the numerators here are the
same but the denominators are different
here instead of writing probability of a
I've simply expanded this out to include
the compliments and that's going to be
probability of B times a probability of
a given B plus the probability of not be
given at times the probability of a
given not be okay so just keep this in
mind and i'll show you how to use it
okay this without without an example
this seems just like expressing one
identity in a different way which which
it is but it's a useful identity okay so
suppose that you have a test all people
in the population are tested for some
medical condition
suppose the measles antibody somebody
here just said they couldn't register
for my class because they didn't have
proof that they had the measles antibody
right so suppose you have the following
information about this medical condition
and the laboratory tests for this
condition right so I think for measles
you can actually take a test or you can
show that you had measles in the past
right so the chance of a random draw
from the population having that medical
condition is point zero one so that's
one in a thousand chance of a false
positive test result is one in a hundred
and the chance of a false negative test
result is I think this is one over 500
right okay so without the test if you
don't take the test its rationale for
you to think that the probability that
you have that condition that is you've
had measles is one in a thousand right
point 0 0 1 but if you take the test and
it comes back positive what are the
chances you have the medical condition
ok well let's define the appropriate
events we've got two events you have the
condition or you don't and you test
positive or you don't ok these are two
different events that probably have some
intersection ok they're probably not
mutually exclusive if they were then the
test would be completely useless right
so there but they have some intersection
how large that intersection is is is a
measure of the power of the test ok the
power of the test is a casually use
to a concept but it is has a specific
statistical meaning and it is related to
the probability of the intersection okay
so the second event is you have a
positive test result or you have a
negative test result be or not be okay
so so let's just write down all the
probabilities we know okay so a was you
have the medical condition that's one in
a thousand we're told that the false
positive okay well what's the false
positive that means you test positive so
you have event B but you actually don't
have the condition so it's given not a
so probability of B given not a is one
in a hundred and a false negative is you
test negative on the test okay so not be
but you actually have the condition and
we're told that's one in 500 okay now so
these are given to us by the the word
statement of the problem we can easily
compute the negatives or the the
compliments okay so probability of a is
that probability of not a is 1 minus
that okay here you have to be a little
bit more careful the complement of B not
be given not a is not be given not a
okay you keep the given the same and you
negate the the conditional they negate
the numerator okay and that's going to
be 1 minus this and similarly here you
keep the given the same you had
probability not be given a so now you
have probably be given a and that's 1
minus this thing okay so you've written
down all these probabilities now you can
just apply
I that bass theorem okay and I've
restated it here with a given B as
opposed to be given a ash the statement
and then you just fill in okay I'm just
filling in and it turns out that it
gives you point Oh 908 well what is this
this is the probability given that you
tested positive the probability that you
actually have the condition will get
this in this case it's only nine percent
so you tested positive but there's only
a nine percent chance that you actually
have that medical condition okay so I
mean and this is not these numbers are
not a typical of many tests okay so keep
in mind what the power of a test you
know as an example I mean I can tell you
that you know we recently had to go
through this test of where you you know
if you if you're pregnant and you're
over 35 then you have to take some tests
I forget what it is but some tests that
costs two thousand dollars that
insurance pays for which you know tells
you whether or not there is a high
probability of having down syndrome and
so on right and I the rule is i think
the rule of thumb that medical insurance
uses or the medical practitioners uses
that if you're over 35 you have to take
that test if you're under 35 it's
optional whether you take the test or
not and the way that they came out with
that cutoff year 35 as i understand it
is that they plotted on an axis age okay
so they plotted age and and they plotted
on this the probability of having a
miscarriage if you take the test and
that increases as your age increases and
then they prodded also the probability
of having down syndrome the
unconditional probability nothing to do
with the test and that also increases
and where they intersect happens to be
35 there is absolutely no scientific
basis for you to take the intersection
of those two but nevertheless that's
what's used okay you know it also has
the nice feature that lots of people
take the test even though it might not
be terribly powerful it might tell you
that instead of having a 1 in 1,000
chance you might now have a 1 in 500
chance if you test positive and if you
test negative instead of a 1 in 1,000
chance you might have a 1 in 2,000
chance but you know but the actual
conditional probabilities will be quite
significant okay but anyway so that's
you want to keep that in mind because in
actual problems environmental problems
you will often face these trades
trade-offs of probabilities and you want
to do that in a scientific way instead
of in a rule of thumb way that doesn't
make sense okay okay in five minutes way
and we're going to talk about
probability distributions
a probability distribution i'm sure
you've probably met these before is
defined as follows a random variable is
a rule okay now remember we first
started this math camp by saying that a
function is what it's a rule that
assigns a number to an input so a random
variable is a rule or a function that
assigns a number to each possible
outcome in a chance experiment okay so
suppose that the chance experiment is
the role of two dice and the each
outcome that I care about is the sum of
the two dice so it could be from 2 to 12
and if and I have some rule or function
that assigns a number to each of those
so I can get to in only one possible way
which is I get a 1 and a 1 and that has
a probability 1 over 36 and so on okay
and the number 7 has the highest
probability 6 over 36 ok so this table
remember that a function could be
specified by a table this table is just
the specification of that function or
the specification of the random variable
the probability distribution function P
of X is the function that assigns the
number to each possible outcome it's the
same as the random variable such that
the sum of all probabilities over the
outcomes is one okay and there's some
definition here okay so where the little
X's are all the different values the
different outcomes okay if you are if
I'm talking about a continuous random
variable that is its I don't have some
finite set of possible
comes but I have an infinite set of
possible outcomes my number X my random
variable X could be 1.1 1.2 one point
two seven one point two seven three one
point two seven three one and so on then
the continuous probability distribution
is given by the indefinite integral from
minus infinity to infinity of the
function f of X where f of X gives you
the probability for an interval around X
ok the probability for any particular
number is always going to be 0 but the
probability for some small interval
around X will be some positive number ok
ok so that is the probability
distribution function and you've
probably met these for example this is
the Gaussian probability distribution
function okay or the normal probability
distribution function okay the
cumulative distribution function or the
density function is the area under this
curve from minus infinity to X to a
particular value X ok so it's the
integral ok and so for a continuous
random variable this is I guess is the
indefinite integral sorry so that's the
entire area and I could take the
definite integral which would be from
minus infinity to some number
okay and for discrete random variables
it's just the summation of all the
values that X of all the probabilities
for every value that X could take okay
that that was a little fast but where
we're going to meet these again when we
do some statistics any questions perfect
understanding okay thank you very much
see I'll see some of you tomorrow okay
take care
you